let's get to our first guest even in the
crazier of 2020 she's been as busy as
ever you can catch her in space force on
Netflix and in her Emmy winning role on
the marvelous mrs. Mays on Amazon Plus
this summer she's back with a new season
of Hollywood game night I love Hollywood
game night take a look it's everybody
focus and here is our first dance can
you hear me there's clearly Clarkson oh
hi Jane hi how are you oh how are you
I'm well I think we're you know all you
know every day is like okay let's say I
feel like every day is today absolutely
um hey you know how much I love
Hollywood game night probably more than
I should because I'm annoying when I
play games but is anyone there this is a
real question yes anyone as competitive
as me this season yes there's a
difference between the two of you and I
will tell you what that is a Evette
Nicole Brown is extremely competitive
but unlike you Kelly
she's stealthy oh she's sneaky about it
you are obvious that's the word you're
obvious and you're transparent and
delightful and charming where she just
kind of sits back in those no like a
Scorpio you know she comes like out of
the depth of the ocean and go spice you
up yeah and you're like what just
happened okay I wish I were more like a
ninja but I'm so obvious oh you gotta be
Kelly that's I love I love the game
night like are you did you did a special
episode though from your house looking
into other celebrity homes which I
thought was kind of cool whose house
made you most jealous I loved my house
the bed it confirmed my design choices
in my partner who's really good at this
too but I mean everybody's house you
wouldn't you couldn't see there's as
much as ours but we have these really
great steps like kind of architectural
II that I never
saw before this way and I was so
thrilled with how we how we had the
books and the shelves and you know we
kind of styled it and we kept it that
way too because it was kind of a mess
with a bunch of family pictures and we
we made some edits we got rid of some
family members sorry really beautiful
display and we kept it that way that's I
love that answer too because I feel like
we always want what we don't have and
that's such a lovely thing to like go
like I like my home I like do I don't
know where you are baby it looks great
and it's beautiful I mean we're in my
home but this literally a set that they
came like it was only allowed like one
person with a mask like I mean this is
right literally it's an actual set in my
living room so that my house definitely
have my initials everywhere not much of
a tool Jane I got a big tail over there
you just don't see it so Jane we have
the pandemic we have the black lives
matter movement there's just a lot of
change and I you know I think that if we
do if we do it right it's a change in a
great direction and I feel like it's
been needed to happen for generations
but I was just curious how you were
processing everything well you know
there's this thing called Twitter and
it's a double-edged sword
and I laughed I've never left harder
than when I go through my Twitter feed
I've never felt as heartbroken as when I
go through my Twitter feed I've never
been as angry and that's the worst part
so it's kind of that's where I get my
news it's been a bit of an addiction for
me and I'm suffering a little bit over
it so I'm not sure where to put it you
know this there is just so much going on
and I feel like I gotta know what it is
and I've got to understand it you know
and I think that that's a healthy thing
because we are at a tipping point this
is this is a really tender moment in our
history and our our nation's of history
you know are we going to survive this
you know the the institutions and and
are we going to tear each other apart I
mean it were really really a edited
pinpoint I
agree I agree speaking of social change
the the marvelous mrs. Mazal deals with
a lot of social change on the show like
how does how do you think the period of
that show reminds you of now well it's
in the early 60s so we wouldn't have the
the this 68-69 stuff there's horrible
assassinations for a few years it is
very white dominated it is very
male-dominated and kind of like today
and the women like women today are
trying to make their mark in comedy and
Midge Mazal is one of those pioneers
because she doesn't she doesn't agree
with the power structure she doesn't
even you know she reminds me of a way of
in a way of Tina Fey and Amy Poehler who
kind of just took a seat at the table
without being invited just they're
entitled to it and I think that's who
Mitch Mazal is and my character Sophie
Lennon is more of the old-school you
know you have to you have to act in a
certain way you have to make fun of your
looks you have to say you're fat
everything has to revolve revolve around
the comedy has to revolve around how you
can't get a date or you can't get a
husband to stay with you and you know
midges stepping up going that's not for
me you know and I say to her well what's
your gimmick she says I don't have a gig
I just you know I tell funny stories so
you know very much like today yeah I
mean it's super sad and and one aspect
but also like super telling subscribe to
my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going